bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fatti j
ed oggi siamo su venice con videogaming
your love che anche se i ragazzi da
secoli che non faccio un horror comunque
ormai ne faccio uno ogni mezzo secolo ma
chi se ne fotte cosa mi consigliate un
nuovo praticamente ragazzi sono sempre
indeciso se parlo no perché chi cazzo ok
siamo nelle opzioni che è perfetto non è
ancora partito se il menu principale
così non oso immaginare il gioco stesso
va beh facciamo ma vai complessiva ma
stiamo calmi che ancora non ho fatto
niente già succedono cose strane non è
normale è una cosa così sono partiti due
cazzo sia perfetto buongiorno siamo in
un posto di merda ragazzi ovviamente
avete capito tutti noi ci siamo arrivati
no no ovviamente come in ogni caso di
videogioco horror non si sa che diavolo
è successo ma chi se ne frega andiamo
avanti per a perfetto ragazzi ma è
chiaro lodi quasi va mirabilandia e di
classi va a gardaland all amia ma garda
ma anche gli piace di cos'era su rumore
ok ho sentito una roba brutta non me ne
frega niente andiamo avanti
tra l'altro ragazzi su questo quando
cammina non è che va avanti dritto
dondola cioè era cosa affanculo che
cazzo successo fiat che cazzo cosa
esploso ragazzi esplosa esploso un tubo
non so se è normale sta cosa ma non
importa andiamo avanti di qua bene così
e allora chiamiamo ogni idraulico se è
possibile perché già lì e che io ho
paura che gli spunti un basilisco
all'improvviso senza nemmeno accorgo è
possibile trattare ma qui lo scoprì sto
gioco che non ho capito andare avanti
che cavolo stai calmo set è tutto qui
non è successo ancora
c'è una pagina c'è una cazzo di pagina
cosa c'è scritto anche dove sei stai
prendendo le mie note e non sai nemmeno
dove sono
c'è qualcosa qui sotto con noi sto
ancora cercando dell'acqua per portarle
alla stanza delle pompe per le tue
chiavi phil fichi pil field bhutan
dobbiamo andare avanti a perfetta una
leva finalmente adesso siamo salvi e
cos'è ma forse per leggere la nota
perfetto non lo sapevo
beh 50 il cazzo me ne frega cosa devo
fare qui spiega a c'è un genere un'altra
non voglio andare l'intento sembrava un
ratto gigante un uccello un qualcosa di
strano hank ragazzi nel calcio succede
c'è qualcosa che si senta equa quale
stanno dando del ratto sporco io non
vorrei dirglielo
è un insulto è un insulto
il cazzo successo frega paga il cazzo
succede a senta lei è molto sexy io ve
lo voglio lo voglio dire sembri un
incontro ok ok scusa scusa non volevo
non volevano voleva non c'è più
non c'è che mi sta prendendo per il culo
e sbagliato così benissimo va bene così
non c'è problema questo non c'era prima
vince dove cazzo siamo ragazzi non c'è
il primo scopo stowe ce ne sono arrivato
di quando aveva trovato di de jong stick
a premi f per usare i gossip perfetto
ragazzi adesso posso segnalare dove da
dove son passato ok perfetto dalla
decisione delle barbe io non voglio non
voglio vedere più quel tizio in vita mia
non ha idea di chi cazzo fosse si può
andare qui sotto non è no secondo me
casco di brutto chi se ne va allora non
vado di là perché menisco va
e che cazzo è successo che cazzo esploso
un petardo ragazzi che cazzo esploso
cosa è successo chiamate un idraulico
perché un assenso vabbè comunque andiamo
di camerino ok ok ok ok perfetto come
non detto come non detto che non ho
detto andiamo da qui da questa parte
perché dall'altra c'è qualcosa che mi
dice che è meglio non andare a c'è un
buco nel pavimento ragazzi c'è qualcosa
e così sta roba
le ragazze da perfetto ci sono dei
segnali che indicano questa via e io
vado di qua c'è un'altra nota perfetto
cosa c'è scritto left right left a è una
strada allora left prima dicendo a
sinistra ok non andiamo a sinistra
aspetto allora già la prima indicazione
era sbagliato a zio era giochi così
posso prenderlo posso prenderlo e di
raiano in testa 9 rock e un'altra 9
effetto ragazzi permetto cos'è cos'è io
disegno meglio cazzo ti non ho capito
buongiorno senta lei che imita gandhi
non è che calzature detto ho detto e
cazzo succede perché mi mandano i
messaggi su skype non ho messo così di
merda ma porca [ __ ]
ma che cazzo ci fai l'iva fire indietro
prima donna riuscisse a ritrovare quel
cazzo di buco per terra sarebbe gradito
trovare qualcosa
aiuto aiuto che cazzo successo sì sì
eccolo veloce veloce dio mio dio mio dio
mio
luca solo vedi questo lo sai dove tele
infilo questo turca madonna quanto sei
bello minchia vai a fare il modello di
abercrombie ragazzi allora facciamo una
cosa io me ne vado via di qua perché già
non mi piace sta zona dove cazzo se è
finito il non lo so qualche parte
spunterà sto cazzo di porto vuoi venire
che sbucano il mio cesso che è successo
perché corre ogni tanto questo corre
frega lega non mi piace non mi piace per
niente che cazzo succede che cazzo
succede perchè si è messo a correre
fatemi capire cosa è successo permesso
c'è nessuno sono uscito per grandissimo
chi è che varietà di posti ragazzi
dovete mandare fatemi capire cosa fare
qui no anche qui dove come cazzo ci sei
arrivato qui lurido
quello stronzo [ __ ] che io
migliori fare tutto quanto ma [ __ ]
mi faccio niente stronzo
vieni qui o ti passo no non ho detto che
ho detto l'ho detto
scherza stavo scherzando stavo
scherzando tuo pezzo di merda a bella
del giro che cazzo si fa è seduto fai la
cacca
ma c'è un buco nel muro non so se ti
interessa ma io passo di qua grazie
mille
continua fuori a fare i bisogni come
cazzo si continua ancora fuori dei
bisogni come cazzo vuoi perché ha dato
io vado di qua stronzo di merda ragazzi
ancora dobbiamo capire che cosa sto
facendo per chi non ha chance c'è un
bivio
cioè prima adesso c'è anche un video qui
sotto ci mancava solo questo allora
andiamo di qua perché ancora non macina
una fine sto gioco devo continuare
andare in giro a caso senza senza meta
per trovare
c'è il giornata di merda ci sarà
un'uscita ragazzi perché sennò non
capisco lo ha lo scopo di sto gioco come
a pisciare così lo so che metti la testa
nei muri e te ne vanti con gli amici
però no ok ok non scherzavo casa vasche
dove si bastardo forte cazzo
raga basta l'ultima io faccio l'ultimo
[ __ ] tentativo e poi mi son rotto il
calma perché faccio niente allora io gli
faccio tutto perché tanto ci abita lui
quindi qualsiasi cosa faccia alla fine
son cazzi suoi
perché ci vive l'ho visto a posto di
merda non io a come cazzo esco dal suo
posto come cazzo ci siamo arrivati il
suo posto perché io giocasta merda
ragazzi io non lo so io non ci sono
troppe domande alle quali non troverò
mai disposta e non mi interessa
dove seguire la luce no perche non devo
a seguirla luce trovare quali siamo
trovato una stanza strana piena di di
valvole adesso non la trovo più o se lo
ringrazia dio grazie ho ritrovato sta
senza dopo anni ancora non ho capito
devo fare qualcosa qui ho trovato però
allora qua dentro ho trovato il globe
stick e non ho capita che cazzo mi
servono ma non me ne frega niente perché
ho trovato sua stanza adesso che esco
dovrebbe esplodere tipo non so con me
freddo fatemi capire che cazzo ci devo
fare qui dentro mi devo buttare qui
dentro ma se mi butto evidente muoio
cosa
raga io mi butto io mi butto poi sento
qualcuno sbraitare ogni tanto a caso non
ho capito perché devo andare vado
ricavato di qua mi piace lurido lurido
debba [ __ ] ducati ho schivato la nota
la nota lo lasciate indietro notano
leggermente dove dovete gli corri corri
lurido stronzo mai qualcosa nella tua
vita non mangiare big mac che non li si
può fare due passi cazzo vai vai vai vai
vai vai vai vai vai veloce veloce la
nota veloce veloce un buco
i corsi sono i voti sono arrivato di
condono riprenderà mai un tradimento
internamente dio santo si presa ma devo
prenderla io non l'ho capito sto
prendendo le note perché l'unica cosa
che spero funzioni perché gli altri non
so cosa fare
io prendo note a caso ormai il vado così
di te ne frega than the dead air gun
vaffan
come fai a essere qui cosa fai facciamo
la facciamo la processione dai tu vai
avanti io ti seguo a ragazzi facciamo
così seguire ha sentito un cazzo vai
avanti mai mentito anche le cuffiette se
vuoi te le regalo più ascolti la musica
c'è qualcosa lì c'è qualcosa c'è una
nota
vai avanti lurido devo prenderla ragazzi
ce che palle che palle che palle che
palle no
apri aprile hai bisogno delle chiavi
proprie saporta quali chiavi apri apri
cazzo guarin chiave ok allora facciamo
così tu mi dà le chiavi solidale chiavi
oggi ti do un gelato tutto pezzo di
merda ragazzi basta vi sono mi sono
rotto il cazzo che non ho capito non so
come si prendono ste chiavi non so dove
sono ste cazzo di chiavi non lo so che è
impossibile è fottutamente impossibile
se avete una soluzione a sta roba di
terreno no perché io non l'ho capita
bavaria e sto bene è stata una con
un'esperienza da dimenticare questo è
sicuro
ema ma poiché che cazzo di meno e questo
ci sembra sembra che mi sia trascinando
cioè così no perché non lo sto cup va
bene una cosa macabra
grazie a un concluso che l'episodio
lasciamo perdere per c'è una cosa
pazzesca e labirintico in una maniera
che non ho mai è buona sono stati come
al solito seguito è piaciuto lasciato un
commento mi piace anche la faccia di
facebook come non i video trovato nella
descrizione delle celebrity discrete noi
ci rivediamo nel prossimo video belle
ragazze
[Musica]